what is up
babies it's the weekend well it's
actually technically Friday for us we
just got back from
California
yes
whoa the hell was
that
oh you better clean that
up they were you didn't
know they're mine they are yours you
can't you can't take it from me don't
play with it inside the house okay okay
what you were just playing with it I
know that's the pro that's the pro of me
a dad you get to do the fun stuff and
I'm not to do do it don't throw it in
the house okay you throw it outside
please don't throw it outside you
dropped one oh
no can I please throw okay go throw one
One ow you threw it at my foot it's
supposed to be on the floor oh sorry
it's okay it's one
go okay that was three no more okay no
more okay so what I was saying before I
was rudely interrupted is that uh
today's going to be a crazy this weekend
is going to be a crazy weekend for us
over here that's f
oh okay go in the front um because a lot
of our furniture finally came in I'm so
stoked because I ordered all this stuff
back in come here come inside come
inside come she has to go bathroom Okay
go you come inside um I ordered all of
this stuff back in
September and since a lot of the stuff
came in I'm buying other stuff so that
we can complete the look so you know
that we've been getting our backyard
done and that's about I want to say
95% done there's still like I feel like
I keep saying this in so many Vlogs but
there's just rock choices and just a
couple things that we need to change
just show them our cool dining table
over there no dude I was just talking oh
talking about it um but yeah a lot of
stuff came in already and I want to show
you I wasn't going to go in the order
but Papa already brought it up so I
might as well just kind of continue that
holy [__] it's cold it's 43° it's cold
ahh [__] hate that guy um yes so one
of the pieces that came in is our
outdoor dining table with chairs this is
all from West
Elm yes West Elm and um I signed up for
their business program the B2B program
so I do get an additional 20% off so if
you own a business sign up and then you
get a really good discount on a lot of
the furniture so yeah we'll eventually
be moving all of this stuff out I'll
make it all cute and I'll put like a
planner and whatnot there but at least
it's here I love it so much gives me
like this really cool Mediterranean Vibe
seats eight it's going to be
amazing this already came in too I don't
know if I shared this with you guys or
not but these pieces here it's going to
be a bonfire that we have to hook
up and uh yeah I got a kind of smaller
one just so it really fits the space I
got to move it over so that there's leg
room here and you don't feel like you're
about to fall off here another piece
that came in oh my God look at them
plane another piece that came in is this
tandem not tandem but like
joints wow there's a crazy ass [__]
tumble weed in here how did it even get
here what the
[__] it was a windy ass day this is
crazy okay well anyway yeah this is It's
like a bed isn't it but it seats two
people I'll put it up up later but yeah
it looks really really pretty here we
have like a little play set well a
pretty big playet coming in holy [__]
that thing changed colors it was green
before we
left it's a little pomegranate tree we
got a lemon tree and that's a lime
tree oh no that's the lime I don't know
it's one or the other but holy [__] that
was green okay sign of times this
Winter's
coming um what else and this right here
we got had to pressure wash everything
and clean it but here is the kick it
spot got it black cuz I just
figured getting it white would just not
be a cute look since we have a black
like it's super modern here right like
there's so much black like our ceiling
is black so getting white in this
section just didn't make any sense so
went with black it's not in its final
position I still have to like I said
pressure wash I have to stain this okay
for my OG's
who remembers this
table they were in all of our Vlogs
maybe like two years ago and on this is
the first coffee table we got these are
all Tao marks so I wanted to keep this
piece just cuz it's I don't know so near
and dear to my heart it's so damn cute
it is [__] old and super weathered
well not even that old T's not even that
old but it's gone through some [__] you
know what I'm saying so I did buy some
stain that I found maybe on Tik Tok or
or something so I got it off of Amazon I
will be treating it and staining it all
over again and hopefully I can restore
it as close to as original look as
possible so that's would be super cutie
but yeah and then we'll like kind of set
all this up cuz we do have friends
coming over in about a week or so we
want our house to look really really
nice why am I so
winded yeah
but also I don't know if you remember
this conversation but we were at some
like um home like what is it called like
a farmers like gardening type store and
Bart wanted this and I was like dude
it's not going to fit with the aesthetic
that we want for our house it's just not
going to look right and blow and behold
he was arguing that it was going to look
right he's like it's [__] sick and
I'm like bro it looks so dumb so yeah
once this whole area gets set up this
has to go bye-bye like not throw it away
cuz it's a great product but it just has
to go
hey come
inside okay and then the insides I'm so
stoked I'm so stoked that we're like
slowly like sinking in Our Roots you
know what I'm saying okay let me bring
these dogs in ta I mean oh my God you
didn't hear that don't tell them don't
tell him I was calling for him when I
meant to call for the dogs please
Mia Cooper Mia
come Cooper yeah you good boy come on
that pop yep I over to the neighbor
don't do that I did it like 10 times
don't do that okay the next thing that
came in are okay so these are my outdoor
rugs one of them going in the the table
area it's so cool I got these off of
Wayfair outdoor look at this like how
cool is that and then this is furry so
it's going to go on the outside and then
this one is really
pretty I don't think you can see it but
kind of it has brown grays and whites I
feel like it's really going to make that
space pop the other thing that came in
is this rug when I got it it was so
beautiful it just never fit the size of
the table or the space like it's a
asymmetrical excuse me asymmetrical rug
you see it's like oddly shaped
too but it just didn't fit the space I
should have got it bigger they just
mistakes were made so I was like [__] it
I'm just going to keep it but when this
little boy came to town hey you he
started biting the carpet you see all
those little holes yep that's this guy
that's
you so look at all that so it was a
perfect excuse to get a new carpet so I
went with rug because they mark it you
can um wash all of their rugs so I went
with it and I got a Jonathan
Adler collab with
rug and let me show you cuz I just did
this whole thing but look at these
colors look at these colors okay one
second okay so I kind of just folded it
in half it's super thin very easy to
move it comes with these like velcro
non-slip pads so once you're ready to
wash it you just remove them you throw
in the washer I don't know what washer
would hold this
I think I got an 8 by10 but look at this
beauty love the pattern can't wait to
swap it out that came
in also ruggable by Jonathan Edler these
guys like look at how beautiful they
look it really made I mean we just got
back from California so ignore this mess
but it really made our Bland kitchen I
mean it's still very beautiful kitchen
it really did make it come to life I
love it so much
also
washable it's okay thank
you um there's so many things so many
updates o what else I bought another one
from some other place maybe Wayfair and
I was like I really like the rable one
it's washable I don't even want to open
that I'm just going to return it so I
won't even waste your time showing you
that the other cool thing that's
happening
is
who all right
so oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh what happened
to have that low where did this guy come
from so we're clearing out Tao space
because a lot of the furniture when we
moved in we kind of just put it wherever
it fit so an example of that he wants me
to save them I'm not saving him is this
we have like two
dressers and like empty cubbies
yeah cuz we're just like put it wherever
it fits for now we'll deal with it later
so none of this stuff has been permanent
I mean you can still see we haven't
added anything to our walls yet we have
so many things we have to add excuse me
sir go
outside um and I'm glad we didn't
because you know we moved into a brand
new build and the Builder guarantees the
house for a year uh with Cosmetics so
our year came up and we did this thing
called Blue taping and blue taping is
you kind of walk through the house and
any imperfections you add a little piece
of blue tape and then the house or the
the Builder will come and then fix all
that so if you see a lot of these little
pieces of tape you
okay that's what it means so I'm kind of
glad that I didn't put any of these
things up I'm telling myself that cuz
like here right like drywall is cracking
so they're going to fix that um
initially I was going to put like a
mirror or something here but I'm glad it
didn't you know because I knew this was
coming up and also I just haven't had a
lot of
time okay so back to ta's room so much
going on isn't there um yeah I found
this really cool you need
help you know how I'm using to slide the
thing his shirt pajamas they
slippers but they have grippies don't
they I fli them upside
down like WI o [__] Wicked Witch of
the West [__] that's funny hey whatever
works yes so back to what I keep trying
to say is yeah went to or I saw Ikea U
I'm going to buy like these cubby like
drawer systems and it's going to be like
in a shape if you can like that like a
u and then that way I can get rid of all
this like crap that he has everywhere
and it'll I'll find a really cool home
for it I'm hoping it all works out and
it looks really nice um if not [__] it
he's stuck with it not a big deal but
yeah I just want the house to flow
better look
nicer um and yeah all of that's going to
happen this weekend so this is just like
one little portion of the whole Vlog so
I can't wait to show you what's going to
happen tomorrow holy
moly good job
Papa and we think this will fit here I
meure well in Aesthetics
wise okay let me help you oh wait wait
wait it's going to hit the
door good job I'm going help this guy
and then I'll be right back so while I
was busy trying to fix the drawers cuz
what I realized okay what's your voice I
have no idea I lost it a few days ago
got sick I don't know but what I realize
is the movers they um didn't install the
drawers correctly so even though they
were working they weren't smooth so me
being the OCD that I was I was putting
the drawers back in I was like wait a
second why is it not smooth and now
they're incredibly smooth so I put all
the drawers back in and I fixed it just
a little humble brag you know what I'm
saying but when I came out I heard all
was vacuuming and I'm like no way no way
no way there's no way that M bear is
doing what I thought what I thought she
was going to do so M bear M bear one of
those type of people where she can't
wait super impatient like crazy and so
she has no right to ever teach taer any
patience because she's the most
impatient person in the world says the
most wait hold on on there's lots lots
of noise let me come back in this
hallway so anytime that there's like a
package that comes in she has to open it
right away and so it wasn't even part of
the plan today to put the new carpet in
and I come out vacuum I was like no way
no way no way and guess what yep wa way
way she moved the whole table all of a
sudden
someone someone that can't even open a
jar can all of a sudden move a stone
table this bad boy Stone dude look at
this this is a stone table this is like
this is like very light that's world
record
powerlifting you break your back over
135 and you Del 500 bre my back and my
heart why do you so this is incredible C
no yeah
right
Meuse me
with your little
Che oh by the way did you ever tell him
about the little Nerf bullet in the AC
event no I love it I'm never taking that
out all right so one day I was walking
by and we saw uh this little Nerf bullet
in the AC event and me and MRA looked at
each other we had to look like yeah
we're never taking that down cuz it's so
[__] cute obviously ta is the one
that shot it in there and it'll forever
be like these Cy kid memories like
everything looks all clean
and then you look up and there's a
little TA of souvenir right
there okay it was a feat because with
rug remember I showed you the velcro
unit that goes on top of the actual rug
you have to align it it does create some
lumps but look at
her my Coral
princess I love it I just I'm going to
vacuum her real
quick so cute I love it do you like it
it feels kind of girly but I like it cuz
I think like um interior design that's a
little bit one but more girly end feels
more cozy and warm okay versus like hard
obsidian like Black River Rock like it
doesn't it doesn't feel you know like
when it feels too like Bruce wanish it
feels like oh this what a lot of family
is not K you know me yeah I think so but
okay I'm going to vacuum and then I'll
put this stuff on top and then we'll see
where we're at at that point
okay so day huh okay so today is day two
of fixing the house putting it together
making it look good decorating the house
I think that's what I want to say day
two of fixing up the house decorating
the house [__] anyway today day two of
whatever we're doing uh papa is about to
pressure wash all of our tile I don't
know if you can see nope reflection hold
on
yes so we have dog throw up we have
stains dirt everything is just effed up
right now and um
whoa
whoa that's pretty
good yeah bark at them no one should
those moves should be barked at good job
do not do that that's so scary so he's
going to pressure wash this entire floor
cuz it's just all sorts of stains
everywhere and he's going to do that
right before we lay down the carpets and
stuff here
too like it's not horrible but I mean I
want to put the carpets down on like a
clean floor also today was the first day
we had a gardener come by and clean up
all of our um yard plants and damn
doesn't make a difference like this [__]
is [__]
beautiful
like
hello there's not a dead leaf in sight
the other thing that they did that I had
no idea cuz I've never
own palm trees in my
life so I don't know if you remember
what El say but let me try to show you
so try to picture of palm tree right got
it okay good um they all have the base
that looks kind of
like these guys right and then like as
the trunk gets bigger these things get
bigger well
fun fact when you leave it out like that
um you run the chance of scorpions
coming in in the winter time cuz they
want to stay warm and they hide in there
so the gardener was like yo let me clean
that for you guys cuz I've already had a
couple of my guys um and they've been
stung by it go I don't want that for you
guys and I'm like Amen brother I don't
want that for you either so they did
this they cleaned all of this stuff up
look at how beautiful they look now but
yeah I had no [__] idea that they do
that
um so the yard looks really nice like
after living here for a year I'm
starting to feel
like yay we're finally sinking Our Roots
in and it feels so nice cuz if you've
been following
us we don't stay in one place for too
long for many different reasons so the
fact that we're doing all of this [__]
you know even though we've had multiple
properties this is the first time that
we've been here long enough to get these
things settled in and it's just so damn
exciting I can't I feel like it's
freaking Christmas for me already and
also ignore the guy on the roof back
there he is putting up my neighbor's
lights we didn't do that we didn't pay
for someone to professionally install
our lights like that we had Papa do it
let me show you and he got the smallest
bulbs ever and I mean I guess it fits
cuz our house is very modern so it looks
very like minimal minimalist
let me see look at these little teeny
little lights he got oh they're actually
on right
now I mean they do the
job but when you
see the professionally installed ones
they look professional and they're
really bright but whatever this has been
the second house uh that we get to put
lights on and I'm just ecstatic that we
even get to put lights on so yay
progress okay
let's go back inside [__] I came out
with my house first Papa's already
wedding the [__] is that oh it's a
truck scared the [__] out of me okay so
on to another thing as Papa's doing
that um I think I showed you that we
moved all this [__] out from tek's room
I picked all that stuff up and it's all
T is taking a nap but it's all
here
it's going to get assembled
tomorrow that's 's
room let's take his room over there uh
and we hired via task rabbit cuz
brother we are not assembling Ikea [__]
anymore because you know why cuz I'm
assembling this [__] I bought these
nightstands a year
ago and I didn't get around to doing it
and now I want to do it and the [__]
instructions are so complicated and very
contradictory it's very
frustrating but I will figure it out but
anyway they're really cute they have
like this little leather pool they're
white this is a leather pool I got two
of them it's going to go
here and here it kind of matches with
these you know with this leather and the
the wood and we got wood fixture here so
I I
got I got these
lamps from oh I got to turn off oh I got
to turn off all these Co I got these
it's going to bother me I left that one
on and I was like I'm Vlogging I'll turn
it off later but OCD much no I really
don't have OCD but it does bother
me
um okay let's go in okay and I got these
lamps from
Amazon they're so
cute look at
these it'll go like
this like
ma'am look how beautiful they
look yeah I'm stoked I'm going to
assemble these and
then shh it was me I made the
noise you're so pretty you're so pretty
yeah so let me fix this and then the
next thing I'm going to
do
is not my favorite but I needs to get
done is kind of sort through all this
junk we all go through this and we stick
our Dirty Fingers in here to see what
snacks we're going to eat so it's just a
freaking [__] show here so I do want to
clean that up and organize it oh I got
to show you what stuff I got from Amazon
I mean um Ikea too I do want to organize
it but look at this so I'm washing the
other round but I got some look at these
it's like a
flat green I don't even know what shade
of green this is It's like a muted
mint these are all from Ikea and then I
also got a beige and then I'm going to
like interchange it so then it'll be
like a beige
smaller um plate and then like a green
bowl or something like it'll just look
really nice and I think for a set of 16
it was 50 bucks I'm like yeah let's do
that so got that got the other round in
here
washing there's a lot going on but I
think it's just been long overdue like
we've had to have done
this I don't know other people get this
[__] done within the first year we're
going on I don't know I even maybe
within the first few months but yeah
we're going into our year mark or we
just passed the year mark and we're
barely getting to it so it's been long
overdue dang look at this guy doing some
manly stuff wow look at him he's look to
see if we were watching
him he does have some good hips though
all right I'm going to make you guys
fall in love make you guys fall in
love look at that
[Applause]
ooo lucky
me oh and I never showed you um excuse
me
ma'am look at how gorgeous this carpet
looks it is perfection I absolutely love
it ignore that we have to mount them at
some point we have to wait for them to
come and take care of all this blue tape
[__] so we probably won't put anything
up that right there is temporary all
those little knick neack p wax back
there is they're not even supposed to be
there that's just the first place I put
them once we moved cuz I didn't want any
of that stuff to break that mirror is
horrible definitely not supposed to be
there I want to get a big old mirr
but we're doing it one step at a time
also hello look how beautiful this is
Ikea dude it's [__]
gorgeous Ikea coming in
clutch okay what else was I going to do
okay let me get back to work
before I I don't know Bart starts
talking [__] in a funny
way okay so ta is still sleeping and
this room's next to his room so I put
the lamp in and I don't like it I don't
think it fits look at
that like it's a beautiful lamp but it's
not the vibe and I mean obviously that
night stand's going to go that's just an
extra mattress cuz we have friends with
kids coming over and they're going to
use that but pretend that's not there
and it's know oh no just even that looks
it's a it's a no for me boss so I'm
going to return
it
bummer it looked more beige or at least
more natural wood like warmer it looked
more like that online and then when I
got it's like super white like what the
f okay so now the moment has arrived we
are putting our carpets down since we
had it rolled up it is rolling up so
we're trying to put some weight on it so
that that it starts flattening itself
out I don't know what I was thinking
getting white we'll see how long it
lasts getting white but I've never had
it white so [__] it we're going with it
we're going to get what we want this
round then we're going to learn our
lessons and then I'll still probably do
it again okay anyway we also got a
pressure posture un plastic okay men
logic men math that's what that's called
um okay so now it's time to get these
bad boys set up we've already moved it
from this location now here the carp we
moved about three four times so I think
it'd be pretty fun to get a little time
lapse going so we could see how long it
takes us to set this area up ding